[Music]
Today we are revisiting the Radeon RX
9070 XT to compare performance using the
latest display drivers with the data
that we originally collected for our day
one review. And we'll be retesting 16
games using the same settings from the
review. Now, I'm doing this because
we've noticed that the 9070 XT appears
to improved since we first reviewed it,
and others have reported seeing the same
thing online. However, to make sure
these improvements have indeed come the
way of improved Radeon drivers, I'll
also be including the GeForce RTX 5070Ti
because if it's also become faster, then
it's more likely that the gains people
are reporting and seeing are due to the
game updates, game patches rather than
Radeon driver updates. Or, you know,
perhaps it could be a bit of both. So,
I'm keen to see what we find. But before
we do, today's sponsor spot is brought
to you by Be Quite and their brand new
range of Lightbase 600 and 900 series
cases. The Lightbase 600 is available
with four Lightwing LX 120 mm PWM fans,
three of which are reversed, so they
look the same throughout the case, while
the more affordable DX model for the
pre-installed fans for those of you that
like to bring your own. Both models
feature a huge LED light bar that spans
the front and top, featuring over 1.2 2
m of ARGB LEDs, and you'll also find
glass panels at the front and side for a
stunning panoramic view of all your PC
components. What we love most about the
light base, though, is the ability to
orient the case multiple different ways
using relocatable feet. You can invert
the case in literally seconds. There's
also room for two 360 mm radiators,
full-size GPUs with vertical mounting
options, and loads more. So, for a full
rundown of what the LightBay 600 and 900
series has to offer, please check the
links in the video description. Okay, so
the test here is pretty basic. As I
said, we're taking the 9070 XT and 5070
Ti and comparing the previously gathered
review data to updated data using the
latest drivers. The Day One reviews
featured 18 games, but I've only been
able to update the data for 16 of them.
Marvel Rivals has been dropped as the
replay previously used for testing is no
longer valid and I had to drop War
Thunder as I'm having a few stability
issues with the game which appears to
affect both Radeon and GeForce GPUs. So,
I'll have to investigate what's going on
there when I have a bit more time. Other
than that though, everything else
remains the same. So, once again, I will
be using my 9800X 3D test system with 32
GB of DDR5 6000 CL30 memory running the
latest version of Windows 11. Okay,
let's get into the data. First up, we
have Star Wars Jedi Survivor. And this
game hasn't received an update this
year, so any performance changes would
likely be due to driver improvements.
That said, though, neither the 1970 XT
nor the 5070Ti have seen any change in
performance since the review data, as
the latest most up-to-ate drivers
provided the exact same performance at
1440p and 4K. So, let's move on. It has
been years since a plague tower reququum
was patched. So again, any changes in
performance here can be directly
attributed to driver changes. And in
this example, we're seeing exactly that.
Previously, the 5070Ti was 8% faster
than the 9070 XT, but with the latest
drivers, they're now neck and neck. Both
averaging 122 FPS at 1440p. And the same
is also true for the 4K testing.
Previously, the GeForce GPU was 5%
faster. Today though, they're both
delivering the same 68 FPS in our test.
Cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty hasn't
been updated since January of this year,
so well before the release of the 9070
XT. So, the gains we're seeing here can
be attributed to drivers. Now, whereas
the review data saw the 9070 XT and
5070Ti delivering virtually identical
results with the updated drivers, the
Radeon GPU is now 4% faster, a very
small advantage, and overall performance
is still very much the same. And it's
also worth noting that the 5072 Ti also
saw a small increase of 4% here. So
there have been some GeForce
improvements as well. In fact, the
GeForce gains are more notable at 4K
where the 5070Ti matches the 9070 XT as
we saw a nice 9% increase for the 1%
lows.
Dying Light 2 has seen a few game
updates, and despite that, the
performance figures from our review data
remain accurate with less than a 2%
deviation using the latest drivers, and
this was true for both the 1440p and 4K
testing.
Dragon Age: The Valgard hasn't seen any
game updates since the release of the
9070 XT, and AMD has also been unable to
improve performance. We did see a 3%
increase for the 5070 Ti at 1440p,
though it's hard to say what's
responsible for this change when
comparing the 4month old review data
with this updated data. Performance at
4K, though, that does remain the same
with less than a 2% deviation.
Marvel Spider-Man Remastered hasn't seen
any updates this year, so the
performance gains we're looking at here
for the 1970 XT can solely be attributed
to driver improvements. And firstly, I
realize the gains here are pretty
shocking. So, I made sure to triple
check the data, and worse still, the
5070 Ti has somehow become 7% slower.
And again, this data was triple checked.
But really, it's the 27% increase in
performance for the 9070 XT that is the
most shocking result here, jumping up
from 169 FPS to 214 FPS. This is a
massive turnaround for the Radeon GPU.
Previously, the review data showed the
9070 XT to be 8% slower. Today though,
it's now 24% faster. That's roughly the
kind of gains we see from Radeon GPUs in
a title such as Call of Duty. Things do
change a bit though at 4K. Here, the
GeForce GPU saw no performance change
while the 9070 XT saw a much more mild
7% uplift. Still, that meant whereas
previously both GPUs delivered similar
performance, the 9070 XT is now 7%
faster.
Next up, we have Hogwarts Legacy. And
this game has received a few updates
this year, though I don't believe any
performance related patches have been
released since the arrival of the 9070
XT. What I can tell you for sure though
is since first collecting our review
data, the 5070Ti has seen no change in
performance, while the 9070 XT has seen
a massive 18% uplift, jumping from 130
FPS to 153 FPS. And that's a big deal
given the Rad and GPU was already
slightly faster in this title. So, we're
now looking at a 21% performance
advantage. Oddly, however, the massive
performance gain seen at 1440p doesn't
apply to 4K. Here, we're only looking at
a 5% gain, though that still meant the
9070 XT was 10% faster than the 5070Ti,
so a respectable performance advantage.
And it's also well worth noting that the
1% lows were almost 30% stronger for the
Radeon GPU.
The Last of Us Part One saw no
performance change for the 9070 XT at
1440p. Though oddly, the 5070 Ti became
4% slower, so not a big drop off, but
now it's roughly on par with the 9070
XT. Then at 4K, we see no real change
for either GPU.
Star Wars Outlaws saw a very minor
improvement for the 9070 XT, 3% at
1440p, which was enough to match the
5070Ti. The 4K data though, on the other
hand, that went unchanged. So
performance overall was very similar
with the 5072 Ti having a very slight
edge. Starfield saw a very slight
performance increase for the 9070 XT at
1440p. A 5% boost taking the average
frame rate from 79 FPS to 83 FPS. The
5070 Ti on the other hand dropped 2 FPS
resulting in the same 83 FPS on average.
Then at 4K the results go largely
unchanged. So here the 9070 XT and
5070Ti are neck andneck with 55 fps.
Delta Force is another title where
performance of the 5070Ti slipped ever
so slightly this time dropping by 3%
down to 168 FPS. The 9070 XT on the
other hand saw a big 14% jump in
performance going from 160 FPS to 183
FPS. And that meant whereas previously
it was 8% slower than the 5070Ti, it's
now 10% faster. So a huge turnaround
there. Then at 4K, the 5070Ti was
previously 7% faster, but now with the
improvements to the 9070 XT, both GPUs
delivered the same level of performance.
Godavore Ragnarok shows a pretty similar
situation. Though in this example, the
5070Ti improved by 2 1/2%. But that is
nothing when compared to the 9070 XT
which enjoyed a 10% boost making it 9%
faster than the 5070Ti. Yet despite the
gains at 1440p we saw no such
improvement at 4K. In fact the data goes
completely unchanged.
Next up we have Counterstrike 2. And
here the 5070Ti produced very similar
results with the latest drivers when
compared to what we saw in the 9070 XT
review. The Radeon GPU though that
became considerably faster boosting
performance by 23% now beating the 5070
Ti. Whereas previously the Radeon GPU
was 10% slower, it's now 10% faster.
Even at 4K, the 9070 XT saw a 14%
uplift. Though that wasn't enough to
match the 507Ti in this example, at
least for the average frame rate, where
the GeForce GPU was 4% faster. Not a big
margin by any means, but compared to
what we saw at 1440p, the results are
quite different. All of that said, the
9070 XT did produce stronger 1% lows.
Stalker 2 has been updated since
collecting our review data, though we
haven't seen any change to the GeForce
performance. That however is not the
case for the 1970 XT which saw a rather
substantial 12% boost jumping from 58
FPS to 65 fps and that allowed it to
match or rather slightly nudge ahead of
the 5070 Ti especially when looking at
those 1% lows. So overall I'd say both
are delivering a pretty similar
experience now. And it's a similar story
at 4K. An 8% increase for the 9070 XT
allows it to match the 5070 Ti, but with
slightly better 1% low performance.
Space Marine 2 was updated in April, and
the patch notes mention slightly
improved performance. Though that's not
what we're seeing here with the 570 Ti,
but I knew the performance we were
looking at previously was due to some
kind of driver issue, and I was able to
confirm this with Nvidia. The good news
is since then Nvidia has addressed the
issue and now the 5070Ti is 36% faster
at 1440p. The Radeon GPU has also seen a
10% performance boost. So overall, when
using the latest drivers, performance
between these two GPUs is quite similar.
Though the tables have turned and now
it's the GeForce GPU that is 6% faster
rather than 14% slower. And that Nvidia
driver issue or bug, whatever it was we
were seeing previously, was even worse
when increasing the resolution to 4K.
The review data showed just 44 FPS for
the 5070 Ti compared to 60fps for the
9070 XT, making the Radeon GPU 36%
faster. However, using the latest
drivers, the 5070Ti is now 63% faster
with 72 FPS on average, while the 9070
XT saw a 10% boost, rendering 66 FPS on
average. So, once again, the tables have
turned on this one, handing Nvidia a 9%
win.
Finally, we have Call of Duty Black Ops
6. And here, both GPUs have seen some
improvement since collecting the review
data. The 5070 Ti saw a more mild 6%
gain while the 9070 XT became 14%
faster. So, a significant increase
there. This means whereas the 9070 XT
was 22% faster in our review, it's now
30% faster. So, a massive performance
advantage in this title. And it's a
similar story at 4K. just a 3% increase
for the 5070 Ti and a much more
substantial 13% increase for the 9070
XT, making the Radeon GPU 30% faster
with the latest drivers.
Okay, so across the 16 games tested, the
9070 XT saw on average a 9% improvement
with the latest game and driver updates.
In comparison, the 5070Ti saw just a 2
1/2% improvement. And this means whereas
the 5070Ti was 2 and a half% faster than
the 9070 XT based on our review data
using the latest drivers and this 16
game sample, the 9070 XT is now 3%
faster. So a swing in the results, but
overall both products remain highly
competitive, delivering very similar
performance overall. The 4K results, on
the other hand, they don't really change
all that much. just a 4% improvement for
the 9070 XT and 3% for the 5070Ti,
resulting in both GPUs delivering the
exact same performance overall at 4K.
And of course, there was nothing in it
previously anyway, so no real changes
here. Now, here's a look at where the
9070 XT did and didn't see performance
gains. The big performance improvements
were seen in Spider-Man, Counter-Strike
2, Hogwarts Legacy, Delta Force, Call of
Duty Stalker 2, Space Marine 2, and God
of War Ragnarok. All showing gains of
10% or greater. We see just six of the
16 games tested saw gains of 5% or less.
And those games included Starfield, Star
Wars Outlaws, The Last of Us Part One,
Jedi Survivor, Dying Light 2, and Dragon
Age: The Valgard. However, at 4K, there
were far fewer big gains to be seen.
Just three of the games tested produced
double-digit improvements with 10 of the
16 games at 5% or less. In fact, there
were seven games that saw no performance
change at all. So, it does seem as
though at lower resolutions, the earlier
RDNA4 drivers weren't as efficient as
they could have been. And this makes
sense as previously the 5070Ti and 9070
XT were very competitive at 4K, but the
9070 XT often fell behind, sometimes
well behind at 1440p. And that really
wasn't something that I expected to see.
If anything, I expected the opposite to
be true, given the GeForce GPU utilizes
GDDR7 memory and therefore has 40% more
memory bandwidth, which you'd expect to
come in handy at those higher
resolutions.
As impressive as these gains are,
overall it doesn't really change much.
Previously, the 5070Ti and 9070 XT were
evenly matched, and that still remains
true today. Overall, they should deliver
a very similar gaming experience. So
then, as has always been the case, it's
the price that will largely be the
deciding factor. Over in the US at
Newegg, the 1970 XT can be had for $700
US. So, not the $600 US MSRP, but we are
getting there slowly. The 5070 Ti on the
other hand that appears to be back up to
$900 US which is an almost 30% premium
and I have no idea why anyone would pay
that. Then over here in Australia at PC
Case Gear it's a pretty similar
situation to what we see in the US. The
970 XTS are currently in stock for
$1,200 AUD whereas the 5070Ti's cost at
least $1,600 AUD making the GeForce
option 33% more expensive. The only
caveat here being that there are four
5070 Ti in stock and available at that
price. Whereas there is just a single
9070 XT and it's the power color
Hellhound with the next cheapest in
stock model being Sapphire's Pulse at
$1,300. But we are looking at just one
retailer here. Anyway, as nice as it is
to see the 97TXT improving as the
drivers mature, feeding into that fine
wine narrative, though RDNA3 kind of
killed the fine wine angle with the lack
of FSR support, but that's a different
story. We won't get into that here. As
usual though, I will continue to track
the progress of these GPUs with future
benchmark content. So, make sure you
subscribe for that. But, as far as this
video goes, we're done for now. If you
enjoyed the testing, please do give the
video a like. As I said, you can
subscribe for more content. And we also
have the YouTube join button or Patreon
if you want to get more Harbor Box
goodness. We have an exclusive Discord
server. We do monthly live streams for
members only. Uh behind the scenes
content. I've been doing a bit of that
lately and Q&A stuff. So yeah, check
that out if you're interested, but if
not, that is perfectly fine. And I would
like to thank you for watching this
video. I'm your host, Steve. See you
again next time.
[Music]